als mensch der sich auf einer bühne
stellt muss man damit rechnen wunder
geburt zu werden das ist im internet so
und das ist ein erstes damit habe ich
auch kein leben ich verteidiger auch
nicht mein gehalt ich habe genug arbeit
und wenn ich die nicht mehr habt dann
schneide ich weder haare darum geht es
nicht es geht und kunst wenn die ein
oder andere kulturelle wandlung in
diesem land stattgefunden hat und
vielleicht nicht mehr alle zum glück
über witze über drücken lassen können
dann ist das vielleicht eine entwicklung
die du dann in dem fall verpasst hast
[Musik]
von sachlicher kritik über einen
veritablen shitstorm bis hin zur kanzel
culture werden künstler und
künstlerinnen in deutschland tatsächlich
von öffentlichen bühnen verbannt weil
ihre meinung nicht genehm ist müssen wir
alle aufpassen was wir sagen in der
öffentlichkeit zumindest wenn wir nicht
gefahr laufen wollen von den digitalen
mob gelyncht zu werden
cancel culture das ist der versuch
unliebsame meinungen stumm zu schalten
13 fragen ist das gegenteil der
versuchen kompromisse zu finden und
damit die erste frage an euch was macht
ihr mit menschen in eurem umfeld in der
familie vielleicht deren meinung nicht
passt dekorieren überzeugen hart
ausgrenzen stadt gerne in diesen tagen
so wir sind angekommen in der ersten
ganz schnellen runde noch ohne worte
bitte ihr habt alle eine position und
die wollen wir jetzt deutlich machen auf
diesem spielfeld damit auch alle sehen
wo ihr ungefähr steht also ist ein sehr
großes meinungsbild was wir jetzt hier
aufs spielfeld bringen wollen ich würde
euch bitten wenn ihr die folgende frage
mit ja beantwortet dann geht bitte ein
schritt in richtung grünes feld und wenn
ihr sagt nee da bin ich eher anderer
meinung er nein dann geht bitte einen
schritt in richtung gelbes fällt so weit
klar gut
hier ist die erste frage für euch ist
die sogenannte cancel culture
tatsächlich eine gefahr für die
meinungsfreiheit ja grün nein geld
ja ja ja nein kann man ja vielleicht
sein
diesen fragen ist es ja manchmal nicht
ganz eindeutig jack and culture ist eine
gefahr für die meinungsfreiheit weil
damit debatten räume eingeschränkt
werden sollen und auf eine sehr perfide
weise ich denke nicht das ganze kalte
die meinungsfreiheit verletzt weil jeder
mensch immer noch zumindest in
deutschland die möglichkeit hat seine
meinung zu äußern und weil cancer
culture als online kultur ein wichtiges
gut ist für minderheiten die sonst nicht
aufgehört werden haben schützt uns
tatsächlich eine so große macht dass sie
künstler und künstlerinnen von bühnen
verschwinden lassen können
würdet ihr weiter richtung grünen gehen
eher nein weiter richtung gelb oder ihr
bleibt stehen
das ist auch möglich du bist
unentschieden offenbar ja also ja aber
wenn man aber ist so groß wirklich noch
befinden verstehen bleibe und darüber
nachdenken muss ich glaube es kommt
immer wieder dazu das schützt uns eine
so große macht haben das ist unter
anderem auch dadurch führt dass leute
wirklich von der bühne verschwinden
müssen ich glaube aber dass man einen
riesigen spielraum daran hat wie man auf
schiffsfonds reagiert und das wir
dringend eine neue kultur der
souveränität im umgang mit solchen chips
brauchen und nicht über jedes stöckchen
springen müssen was uns hingehalten wird
in deutschland ist es so
das kernziel culture sind ein bisschen
anders gelebt wie jetzt in den usa in
den usa wenn leute wirklich gecancelt
deren karrieren wenn quasi beendet
ich habe irgendwie das gefühl bei uns
wir sind kernziele culture vorgänger
irgendwie immer so ein ehrliches aktion
so ein bisschen so ein karrierebewusst
für die leute wird keine wahnsinnige
aufmerksamkeit von ihrem jeweiligen
lager was deshalb nicht so wirklich
canceln ist also irgendwie bewenden
diesen begriff zwar an aber bekämpfen
nicht möglich leute darf kunst und
satire wirklich alles also zum beispiel
auch witze über minderheiten machen er
ja eher nein sagt ihr beiden ihr seid
aber unsicher aurel warum ist so sicher
ich bin ich unsicher also bis zu dem
punkt wo wir sagen auch über
minderheiten wir zu machen wenn man
sagen würde darf kunst und satire alles
würde ich sagen ja okay da kann ich
stehen bleiben aber ab dem punkt
minderheiten und sage ich nein es darf
sie nicht kunst und satire darf
selbstverständlich alles und es ist
nicht mal die frage was darf kunst und
satire sondern es muss alles dürfen
kunst muss alles setzt ist es gibt gar
keine grenze prinzipiell kann darf kunst
und satire alles aber warum sollte man
sich wie ein arschloch benehmen und nach
unten trinken alles klar wir werden
darüber gleich noch länger diskutieren
wir gehen jetzt gleich erstmal in die
zweite runde die positionen sind jetzt
einigermaßen klar geworden ihr steht
alle an unterschiedlichen feldern man
sieht daran auch es gibt kein schwarz
und weiß also weil deswegen gibt es ja
auch verschiedene positionen jetzt
gerade auf diesem feld ich bin mal
gespannt wie sich das weiterentwickelt
mein ziel ist es natürlich am ende alle
in die mitte zu führen weil ihr quasi im
feld des kompromisses in der mitte
zusammen kommt und einen konsens findet
ob das klappt wenn wir mal sehen alle
die jetzt im gelben feld stellen ihr
seid jetzt gefragt beim stichwort cancel
culture reden wir ja vor allem über die
fälle lisa ecker zum beispiel oder
dieter nuhr das haben wir es nun sehr
viel diskutiert ich würde gerne mal
einsteigen mit einer umfrage unter
normalen bürger und bürgerinnen
allensbach-umfrage von 2009 10 haben
fast 60 prozent der deutschen gesagt
eine repräsentative studie in der
öffentlichkeit zitat kann ich mich nicht
frei sondern nur mit vorsicht äußern
angesichts dieser zahl müssen wir nicht
tatsächlich aufpassen dass die meinungs-
das halt nicht verloren geht also ich
sehe es sehr positiv dass sich menschen
überlegen bevor was sie sagen bevor sie
den mund aufmachen das ist etwas was ich
auch erst lernen musste
aber das ist tatsächlich ganz gut ich
sehe das als fortschritt das heißt du
gehst nicht nach vorn auf keinen fall
gehst du nach hinten ja ich bleibe hier
also dieses design das gar nicht mehr
sagen würden so weiter
dafür hab ich überhaupt gar keine
sensibilität oder so dahinter steht die
angst dass man irgendwie zum beispiel
ein shitstorm abbekommt die habe ich
meinen hey wenn du müll erzählt dann
musst du sein würde rechnen also wenn
ich mich jetzt hinstellen und menschen
mit behinderungen beleidige oder so dann
ist es dann habe ich es verdient dass
ich dafür einen schutzraum bekommen der
schützt da muss mich ja nicht aus der
öffentlichkeit verjagen
aber der shitstorm ja ich meine nicht
habe ich mir ja eingeheimst also so
frage an grün jetzt seid ihr gefordert
vor oder zurück laufen das könnt ihr
selber entscheiden wir haben in
deutschland ja viele probleme eines
davon heißt rassismus manche sagen es
ist ein großes problem andere sagen das
ist ein richtig großes problem ist es
angesichts dessen nicht absolut
verständlich dass man zb beim thema
rassismus über streng vielleicht sogar
hinschaut und genau schaut welchen
künstlern und künstlerinnen eine bühne
geboten wird er ja nach vorne kommen
eher nein
stehen bleiben oder zurück
das ist interessant jetzt ist sondern
nach vorne gegangen weil du sagst ja das
stimmt er ja da muss man vielleicht
sogar über strengen hinschauen
ja also da wäre für mich genau die
grenze dessen also wenn es um ethische
sachen sind wenn es diskriminierung ist
aufgrund von hautfarbe zum beispiel dann
ist da etwas wo die zivilgesellschaft
genau hinschauen sollte und auch sogar
über bestimmte gesetze hinweg eben
zeigen sollte das akzeptieren wir nicht
warum bist du zurückgegangen ich glaube
dass rassismus problem natürlich gibt es
ein rassismus problem in deutschland ein
ganz massives ist vor allem ein
institutionelles es ist ein konkretes
ist eines wo man dran arbeiten muss
beispielsweise wenn es um die ganze
polizei debatte geht die wir jetzt aber
an der wir jetzt gerade herumkauen so
ich glaube aber daraus pauschal
irgendetwas über debatten im
öffentlichen raum abzuleiten dass erst
mal falsch und vage weil dahinter diese
frage steht was ist eigentlich
rassistisch und wer entscheidet das ja
genau wenn jetzt auch gar nicht so viele
beispiele einfallen wo jetzt irgendwie
die rassisten und rassisten und
sozusagen auf die bühnen des
öffentlichen raumes drängen und von dort
irgendwie ferngehalten müssen so es für
mich irgendwie erzeugten falsches bild
einer einer notlage die es so nicht gibt
es für mich hat anna da schon sehr viel
von meinen argumenten gesagt erstens ist
ja im grundgesetz festgelegt dass jeder
seine meinung sagen darf und diese
meinung wird ja immer irgendwie jetzt
die wird ja verscherbelt also wir leben
in einem land mit dauer des krimis also
es ist gar nicht festgelegt was ist denn
eigentlich rassismus dass ich einfach
ganz ganz wichtig finde dass es nach wie
vor ein publikum gibt das sich
entscheiden kann einzuschalten oder
abzuschalten
und ich glaube wenn jemand sich
rassistischer vorurteile bedient hat das
was mit bildung zu tun und da sollten
wir an und den hebel ansetzen aber nicht
vor anfang mit einer verbotspolitik gut
wir haben jetzt gehe auf eine sache ein
wir haben jetzt noch nicht über verbots
debatten gesprochen wir reden in der
ganzen debatte eigentlich gar nicht über
verbote bisher würde wenn irgendjemand
entscheiden kann was zum beispiel
rassismus ist was antisemitismus ist
dann sind es doch die betroffenen davon
und nicht irgendwelche typen
auch sehen wie ich das sehe ich völlig
anders denn ich als bisexueller man kann
ja auch eine ganz andere meinung zu
homosexuellen feindlichkeit und
feindlichkeit gegenüber bisexuellen
männern
ich habe kein problem mit dem wort
[ __ ] keinen der problem mit witzen
die über mich gemacht werden
ganz im gegenteil ich trage meine meine
meine eigene art nicht freue mich her
und sondern ich bin auch ein blinder
mann und ich finde es scheiße sehr gut
da gibt es auf den beiden dissenz wie
man auch anderen positionen übrigens
sehr gut deutlich sehr gut und wir gehen
gleich noch ein bisschen tiefer in die
diskussion ein auch mit persönlichen
erlebnissen ihr habt alle die ein oder
andere erfahrungen mit storms und
gegenwind und so weiter bekommen und
verschiedene schlüsse daraus gezogen
darüber sprechen wir gleich fragen
natürlich auch an euch wie geht es euch
habt ihr schon mal jemanden quasi
gecancelt oder verstoßen weil er eine
unliebsame meinungen hatte wie geht ihr
damit um
oder ist es vielleicht richtig war schon
mal gegenteilig passiert habt ihr schon
mal probleme in meinem freundeskreis
oder auf der arbeit oder so bekommen
weil ihre meinung geäußert hat die
anderen leuten nicht gepasst haben und
wir reden jetzt erstmal über
grundgesetzkonforme meinungen um das
ganz deutlich zu sagen wir gehen jetzt
in die dritte runde da gibt es ein paar
persönliche erlebnisse und dann wird
vielleicht auch ein bisschen heftiger
diskutiert
wir fangen wir mit dir an wir wollen ja
über das thema meinungsfreiheit und die
grenzen der meinungsfreiheit sprechen du
hast im september war es glaube ich
vergangenen september einen appell für
freie debatten räume so habt ihr das
genannt gestartet um zitat das denken
aus dem würgegriff zu befreien
generell habt ihr gesagt sei die
meinungsfreiheit bedroht wer bedroht sie
die öffentliche meinung
dann würde vielleicht sagen mehrheits
diktatur ist dann gegeben wenn gar nicht
mehr das gefühl da ist ich kann jetzt
wirklich frei denken auch und das auch
relativ frei äußern sondern ich muss
eben diese angst haben und das ist
leider eben das schwieriger weil das ist
nicht so klar ist wer sie bedroht das
können ja unterschiedliche gruppen seien
aber du hast das wort mehrheits diktatur
in den mund genommen ist das nicht ein
bisschen diktatur
ja das ist ein begriff von alex
tocqueville der das schon im neunzehnten
jahrhundert befürchtet hat als paradoxon
der demokratie der gesagt hat wir haben
das jetzt zwar und wir versuchen eine
offene gesellschaft zu haben aber was
passiert wenn die mehrheit einen so
großen druck auf einzelne ausübt dass es
nicht mehr möglich ist eine kulturelle
selbstverständlichkeit zu hinterfragen
und das was kulturell selbstverständlich
ist ist nicht immer das was das beste
ist und ein fortschritt ist dann gar
nicht mehr möglich und diktatur ist ein
hartes wort gebe ich zu aber es macht
das ganze deutlich wo das hingeht du
willst dich in einer solchen ich will
deine position klar kriegen
das würde ich nicht sagen es ist eine
gefährliche tendenz gerade was auch
digitalisierung und soziale medien
angeht wenn wir immer weiter
einschneiden und die schneiden diese
meinungsfreiheit und dann ist es eine
irgendwann welche konkreten negativen
konsequenzen hat diese meinungsdiktatur
ist ein schlagwort ich benutze auf dich
also was konkret schränkt ich darin ein
einfach zu sagen was du denkst auch wenn
es beispielsweise diskriminierend ist ja
auf mich persönlich eigentlich weiß ich
nicht ich kann mich relativ frei bewegen
aber es geht ja auch um diejenigen die
das nicht können beziehungsweise
diejenigen die eben das befürchten
müssen dass sie ihren job verlieren oder
dass sie nicht mehr irgendwo eingeladen
werden dass sie und zwar wegen einer wie
du sagst grundgesetz konformen meinung
ja die man nicht mögen muss und die man
auch verachten kann aber dass diese
zivilisierte debatte nicht mehr
stattfinden kann über solche meinungen
halte ich nicht für notwendig ich frage
mich ob also ob diese gefahr wirklich
gegeben ist weil ich habe das gefühl wir
haben in deutschland schon relative
vielfalt an verschiedenen medien
hannah du sehr konservativen medium war
in letzter zeit vor allem ihr
chefredakteur auf der anderen seite
haben gibt es dann selbst selbst meine
plattform die ein bisschen linke
ausgerichtet ist und so weiter und ich
habe das gefühl dass wir uns also dass
diese medien sich da schon alle ihre
berechtigung haben und sich da sehr sehr
gut in deutschland die hand geben was
ich habe
das gefühl dass es dann sehr sehr guten
austausch gibt und klar dass fühlt sich
dann öfter mal so an als jetzt sind die
konservativen besonders stark jetzt sind
die linken besonders stark jetzt ist die
mitte irgendwie besonders stark aber
eigentlich habe ich das gefühl dass wir
ein ganz ganz gesundes gleichgewicht
haben das mal und mal in eine andere
richtung ausschlägt aber ich würde schon
gesehen wenn man in der in die
vergangenheit guckt dass da die button
räume größer waren das auch die seiten
vielleicht etwas gleichmäßiger verteilt
war
ich sehe schon heute und wenn du zum
beispiel die öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk nimmst und was dort eben
gesendet wird eine eine sowie um starke
1 sailler oder einfach mit tollen aus
sowie hin
aber es ist interessant hanna ist altona
fragen wann ist natürlich ist natürlich
da ist gerade nach vorne gelaufen das
ist ja interessant weil du wurdest
offenbar überzeugt von dem was er gesagt
hat das es eigentlich eine
meinungsvielfalt gibt richtig habe ich
mich deswegen überzeugt oder auf jeden
fall
ein etwas sozusagen angeschlossen was
ich auch denke nämlich dass diese ganze
polarisierung diskussion ein stück weit
eine absolute blasen diskussion und
deswegen zunächst auch immer gefährlich
diese ganze rede von meinungs- korridor
von gesinnungs korrektur oder auch vom
würgegriff also ich hab ja gut zum
beispiel so halb gecancelt
nein welcher frischen krediten nein habe
ich nicht aber ich jetzt eben nicht
unterschrieben weil ich da zum beispiel
wie eben die rede von würgegriff auch
übertrieben waren
du hast aber auch gesagt nur im
interview ich glaube schon dass ich
manchmal sachen nicht so deutlich sagen
wie ich sie sagen könnte weil da auch
eine angst ist ja und inwiefern hat
bestimmt auch einfach mit meiner
persönlichkeit zu tun ich will immer
dass alle mich mögen und polarisierte
deswegen vielleicht nicht so gerne
was ist so klar dass man bestimmte
sachen raus haut auf social media vor
allem natürlich auf twitter was für
diese dinge die absolute hölle plattform
ist dann kommt der schutzdauer so und da
habe ich nicht immer lust drauf und es
ist halt eben auch so dass häufig sachen
einfach völlig unterkomplex gelesen
werden und dann lesen die leute halt die
überschrift und rasten aus als das
nachvollziehen auch wenn du hast ja auch
schon ein paar chips hinter dir ja das
ist ja ich meine das ist ja das was sie
beschreibt das kann einem ja durchaus
machen das selbst wenn man halb in der
öffentlichkeit steht wie hannah zum
beispiel ja das spannende ist immer dass
man merkt wenn man wenn man neuen
content veröffentlicht dass es erstmal
erst kommt der zuspruch weil er es
erstmal in der babbel bleibt und oftmals
wenn etwas aus der bubble rauskommt dann
kann die situation komplett eskalieren
und es kann auf eine erschlagen wird
müsse wahrscheinlich meint das wäre dann
so ein artikel aus seiner babbel
rauskommen und plötzlich hast du so
einen gegenwind ich habe aber das gefühl
dass wenn dieser gegen bin groß genug
wird dann solidarisieren sich wieder
genug leute mit dir dass es wieder so
ein bisschen ausgeglichen wird auf der
anderen seite heißt das aber auch dass
man ein verdammt dickes fell braucht um
sich öffentlich äußern zu können
das so geht man ja die öffentlichkeit
das ist die frage ist dann wäre es nicht
wünschenswert dass man auch noch darüber
hinaus menschen und meinungen akzeptiert
die eben nicht ganz und dickes fell ja
die ja definitiv natürlich man kann das
nicht von jeder person erwarten dass sie
aus genau diesen gründen
der öffentlichkeit ist sondern man muss
natürlich schon da ich meine gut diese
debatten räumen wir sind dann in dem in
dem moment ich meine wir haben hier so
ein debatten raum gerade wo wir
versuchen solche sachen auszudiskutieren
und wo man leute auch versuchen muss in
einem geschützten einem geschützten
umfeld deren meinungen mal raus zu
lassen hat ist der youtube schützt nicht
statt das ist ja mit ein grund warum ich
jetzt gerade so einen halben schritt
nach vorne gegangen ja was ich aber
total negativ finde das habe ich nur
halt nach vorne gegangen sind die medien
in den medien finden einfach ganz
bestimmte dinge so in diesem format jahr
aber sonst nicht staat also das kann ich
als erfahrener medienkritik da muss man
immer ein bisschen abwägen naja wenn ich
eingeladen der in eine sendung und ich
muss dann text hinschicken
und ich werde dann eben nicht mehr
eingeladen weil dieser text einfach
nicht stattfinden da ab wann hat sich
mit muslimen beschäftigt oder mit heißen
themen beschäftigt dann ist das eben
keine meinung sind dann gehen wir noch
mal daran du du hast ja das am eigenen
leib erfahren du fühlst dich selbst als
cancel culture opfer es muss man dazu
sagen du hast über jahrzehnte hinweg in
einem theater in hamburg gespielt immer
wieder und regeln in allen also ja ja
aber in diesem theater auch regelmäßig
und dieses engagement wird jetzt nicht
verlängert du sagst wahrscheinlich weil
muslimische miteinanders und sich
wahrscheinlich kann über deine türken
witze aufgeregt haben und sich beleidigt
gefühlt haben der intendant dementiert
das muss man auch dazusagen der sagt das
stimmt überhaupt nicht war nicht so ich
bin ja nicht verpflichtet immer einen
künstler weiter zu verpflichten so oder
so du fühlst dich als opfer da kann ich
doch nicht als opfer dar weil er im
verein und das theater ja selber
entscheiden kann mit wem sie arbeiten
wollen oder nicht
das opfer ist in diesem falle die freie
kunst denn es gibt er und da ist die
lücke bei diesem ganzen kette cancelled
allerdings in dem moment ich bekam ja
gar nicht die chance mich mit der mit
einem kellner zu unterhalten und ich
habe in diesem theater wie gesagt seit
30 jahren gearbeitet und mit allen
muslime müssten keinen spaß gehabt war
die wussten dass ich tue und mich kennen
fernab der bühne und wussten dass es
eine bühnenfigur in diesem fall war es
aber halt so dass diese kenner mich hat
nicht kannten und die haben wir was weiß
ich ein kulturschock gehabt oder und das
gespräch wurde verweigert und die wurde
halt vorher eigentlich gesagt heute
kommt kate geht es mal ein bisschen
anders zu sondern es wurde in
vorauseilendem gehorsam wurde gecancelt
kann es auch sein dass der intendant ich
einfach nicht mehr so lustig findet und
deswegen das engagement nicht weil das
kann natürlich sein dass bald ein
eigenartig wenn das drei intendanten in
einem jahr sind also denn das hat den
anderen theater und auch stattgefunden
bei einem anderen theater ging es darum
dass ich witze gemacht habe über
migration das ist auch ein heißes thema
über das man keine witze macht und in
diesem land übrigens nur hinter
vorgehaltener hand spricht puzzle und
das dritte thema ist die stadt monheim
hat mich wieder ausgeladen wegen
verharmlosung rechter gefahr weil ich
mich satirisch über den slogan wir sind
mehr ausgelassen habe also drei
beispiele innerhalb eines jahres ich
freue mich dass du seit 30 jahren kunst
macht auf eine bühne das ist all das ist
wirklich so die das rückgrat der
kleinkunst und darüber hinaus landschaft
dieses landes aber wenn seit 30 jahren
vielleicht die ein oder andere
kulturelle wandlung in diesem land
stattgefunden hat und vielleicht nicht
mehr alle zum glück über witze über
türken lachen können dann ist das
vielleicht eine entwicklung die du dann
in dem fall verpasst hast aber es gibt
ja nicht nur die ouvertüre ist einfach
das rechte lager in das alles rein
gesteckt wird und dass ein paar drei auf
den bäumen ist und das wird gegessen als
mensch dass sie auf die bühne stellt
muss man damit rechnen runter gebucht zu
werden das ist im internet so und das
ist ein erstes damit habe ich auch kein
problem ich verteidige auch nicht mein
gehalt ich habe genug arbeit und wenn
ich die nicht mehr habt dann schneide
ich wieder haare darum geht es nicht es
geht und kunst gibt aber was ist sagte
der künstlerische wert von der tagung
roten publikum nicht mehr gestattet wird
das zu hören was sie hören wollen
ob das reicht nicht
die leute wollen mich hören habe ich
nicht aber wenn das publikum ihn nicht
mehr sehen möchte dann wird das publikum
möchte es dann wird es eine neue bühne
geben führt natürlich 14 der bühne geben
du hast ja auch noch verschiedene
auftritte aber du hast gesagt in einem
interview die treiber dieser kennzahl
culture seien vor allem zitiere ich
zitiere vor allem junge künstler
kollegen meinst du meinst du zum
beispiel diese ja ich bin der meinung
und das gestehe ich den ich bin
tatsächlich der meinung dass findet ja
auch spannend an dieser diskussion
und da auch mit ein grund für mich
hierher zu kommen ich bin der meinung da
gebe ich dir recht dass ich vielleicht
ein verknöchert des alters entertainment
er ungetüm bin und dass die neue
generation ganz bestimmt die welt ändern
kann und alles so machen können wie sie
wollen
aber mich deshalb also die kunst für die
für mein publikum zu beschneiden und die
welt rückwirkend zu ändern ist einfach
nicht richtig in irgendeiner form muss
man ja wenn sich die zeiten verändern
eine gewisse sensibilität gegenüber den
zeiten mitbringen und das ist nun mal so
wir haben wir haben zum beispiel innen
in deutschland wir haben über jahre
besonderen humor auf kosten von
minderheiten gemacht und jede bewegung
braucht eine gegenbewegung und diese
gegenbewegung gibt es jetzt und ich
denke wenn wir in dieser ganzen
rassismus debatte auch in den medien
auch in der comedy und so weiteren
schritt nach vorne machen müssen müssen
auch künstler wie du anfangen sich ein
bisschen zu verändern und zu sehen und
sagen hey ja ich habe über minderheiten
gemacht und jetzt entwickele ich mich
als künstler neu und veränderung nicht
mit der zeit die fertiger den ansatz
genau aber dann hätte ich bin ein
künstler der seit 30 jahren ja quasi auf
der bühne steht und diese debatten habe
ich also wegen tausender von tieren
gehabt ich habe mich ganz nackt
ausgezogen und lustige tierchen mit
meinem geschlechtsteil gemacht das waren
ganz furchtbar viele leute ganz
widerlich und das problem ist ich hätte
das dann auch lassen können weil die
prüden gesagt haben ich so rücksicht
nehmen auf minderheiten wie das nicht
mögen
ich habe mit der nehme auch mache witze
über behinderte von denen es ganz
furchtbar viele behinderte gibt die ist
das super finden und sagen weise in
meine shows rollen
das heißt ich bin verantwortlich für
mein publikum aber nicht für deutschland
ich würde ganz kurz die
kulturredakteurin mit ins boot holen zu
beobachten ist das ja auch sagen wir mal
aus professioneller sicht erleben wir
also gerade
eine form in diesem fall von von canceln
oder ist es eine neuausrichtung von
humor wie würdest du es bewerten also
ich finde ich finde es ganz schwierig
wenn man so tut als würden die jungen
das alte wollen und die alten das andere
rechnen das macht total vereinfachte
vorstellungen davon auf ok auf der einen
seite ist irgendwie die doofe alte
satire die die ganze zeit da so geil
fand irgendwie rum gestanden hat und
dazu über behinderte gemacht hat und auf
der anderen seite ist halt die pc
avangard die jetzt alles verändert so
also ich würde immer die fahrenden dafür
hochhalten zu sagen das ist auch
natürlich die jungen eine extrem
heterogene gruppe sind von denen das nur
momentan so ist das eine bestimmte art
zu sprechen der bestimmte art politisch
zu orientieren agitieren eine bestimmte
art vielleicht teilweise auch kunst und
medien zu machen
durch soziale medien sehr laut ist und
das finde ich auch erstmal weder
schlecht noch gut ist ist ein phänomen
und dadurch mit sicherheit was
verschoben und vorangetrieben so es gibt
aber auch noch ganz ganz ganz viel
angriff und ich würde auch immer sagen
und das ist in dieser verkürzung dann
vielleicht jetzt auch schon erschütternd
würde ich aber wird zu über minderheiten
können natürlich subversiv seien ja sie
können natürlich das zur kenntlichkeit
entstellt was in den menschen vorgeht
ich habe manchmal das gefühl bei diesen
künstlern die für eine sache kritisiert
werden entweder verstecken die sich so
einer kunstfigur dass ich nicht mehr
keine echte haltung mehr erkennen kann
sondern sie reproduzieren nur sachen
also entweder ihre politische klischees
oder rassistische klischees tiere
produzieren die nur und ich kann nicht
sagen wer ist diese person sondern ich
sehe nur blank dieses ding und klar man
kann immer ich kann alles interpretieren
ich kann sagen ja da zeigt sie uns jetzt
den spiegel der gesellschaft vor
oder ich kann sagen er gut ist es
eigentlich
üble hetzrede aber warum kann man denn
da nicht die unschuldsvermutung geld
nicht genau was auch etwas aber ich
lasse ja ich lasse ja die ich bin ja ich
sage auch nicht dass diese leute sollen
verschwinden oder sonst sondern das ist
dann eher so eine ist es dann eher eine
art und weise wie ich die gag technik
unter die satire dahinter bewährte weil
ich denke mir so ok bau doch den
doppelten boden ein mach's doch und
macht ihn nicht nur dass ich ihnen
irgendwie in seiner fünften meter ebene
an einem augenzwinkern irgendwo raus
interpretieren muss es fällt mir
manchmal bei manchen künstler
tatsächlich schwer zu sagen was ist das
das ist nur ist es jetzt noch rassismus
oder das ist satire
gerade bei dem humor denke ich der wäre
doch der ort wo wir gemeinsam so über
solche sachen lachen können und da ist
man doch oft mit einem augenzwinkern man
kann über sich selbst lachen und man
kann aber auch mal grenzen austesten und
das ist der ort wo wir diese debatte
führen aber welche also keine negativen
auswirkungen verstehe ich aber weder zum
beispiel dieter nuhr lisa ecker hat die
großen qfn die über die wir die ganze
zeit reden müssen weil wir nichts
anderes zu tun haben die werden nicht
gecancelt die haben keine negativen
auswirkungen davon und und dieter nuhr
ist ich glaube es gibt wochen tage an
denen lebt man durchs fernsehen und
sieht nur noch sein gesicht aber darf
der menschen haben keine negativen
auswirkungen aus den negativen wenn du
so einen shitstorm aushalten muss dir
gerne nach dem stück zurückgehen weil
darüber darüber reden wir nämlich gleich
über die negativen auswirkungen erst mal
die kurze frage an euch wie seht ihr das
wo sind die grenzen der meinungs- und
kunstfreiheit gibt es sie überhaupt und
wenn ja wo liegt sie für euch an einem
mit der euch beleidigt oder an witzen
insgesamt die beleidigen oder gibt es
überhaupt gar keine grenzen schreibt
gerne wieder in die kommentare ja dann
reden wir nochmal drüber über negative
folgen diesem von möglichem canceln
die ist das passiert du hattest in
deinem podcast eine person der
vorgeworfen wird dass sie gewalttätig
gegenüber frauen ist vorgeworfen ich
glaube nicht verurteilt und daraufhin
hast du einen shitstorm erlebt was ist
passiert genau wie du gesagt hast wir
hatten eine person zu gast gegen die
standen vorwürfe im raum und es wurde
dann zwar auch unsere allererste podcast
folge muss sich dazu noch mal sagen und
dann gab es so einen pass der auf
instagram viral gegen der auch uns
namentlich
land hat und unseren podcast realitäten
auch namentlich genannt hat es war so
dass wir das sehr vage sozusagen
vorwürfe auf instagram rom ging
daraufhin wurden wir dazu angehalten
diese folge zu löschen was sich aber
nicht so leicht gestaltet hat weil die
weil wir im auftrag produzieren einfach
und der podcast ist nicht unser podcast
und dann haben es tatsächlich auch
hingekriegt das innerhalb von einer
woche
diese personen gegen die die vorwürfe im
raum standen von der folge entfernt
wurde
wir haben den disclaimer vor die folge
gepackt und die person um die es ging
wurde halt raus geschnitten und
eigentlich die forderungen wurden
erfüllt so zu sagen du hast dich kontakt
schuldig gemacht
ja genau ich habe mich kontakt schuldig
gemacht weil ich war ja nicht die person
die gewalt ausgeübt hat sozusagen
sondern ich habe ich wurde mit einer
person assoziiert und habe ihr in dem
podcast eine plattform gegeben ohne dass
zu dem zeitpunkt zu wissen das aber auch
nur vorgeworfen wurde oder war das jetzt
festgestellt
genau das wurde der vorgeworfen also es
gab jetzt keine gerichtlichen beschlüsse
es gab auch keine detaillierung dessen
was vorgefallen ist oder so ist es halt
einfach auch aus der opferperspektive
also eine person die halt missbrauch
erfahren hat oder gewalt erfahren hat
sozusagen diesen diese forderung ihr
dürft einer person der das überhaupt
vorgeworfen wird keine plattform geben
aber da müsstest du eigentlich kate
zustimmen er sagt ja das darf so was
darf nicht sein dass du jetzt auch noch
dafür angegriffen wirst weil du dich mit
jemanden unterhält der mutmaßlich
gewalttätig war aber hier als
feministisches also die cdu und auch
feministische podcast drinnen müssen
natürlich auch zuhören und müssen
natürlich auch irgendwie ernst nehmen
dass diese vor bevor im raum stehen und
wir müssen uns ja auch überlegen wofür
stehen wir und wo finde ich und so
gewalt oder missbrauch sich da auf jeden
fall schon noch mal eine grenze für mich
ich habe auch selber schon mal gecancelt
ich hab auch schon mal selber eine ganze
cancer kampagne geleitet nämlich gegen
kelly damals das war 2009 10 mit seiner
co moderatorin singa kelly stumm
schalten die ist die kampagne mode sogar
prämiert aufgrund ihres großen
engagements was war was ist der
unterschied zwischen dem einen künstler
und dem anderen kennt aus seiner sicht
der unterschied ist kelly ist eine
person dieselbe der selbst vorgeworfen
wird sozusagen gewaltvoll gewesen zu
sein ich ging war jetzt nicht gewaltvoll
aber wurde trotzdem auch die cancelled
zu einem gewissen grad
kelly ist mittlerweile im gefängnis für
die sachen die ihm vorgeworfen wurden in
unserem fall hatte sich einfach leider
nie geklärt oder ist noch erklärung im
gange keine ahnung
und ich denke halt so ein kellys ganze
kunst beruht darauf liebeslieder zu
machen und zu performen wenn man da weiß
einfach dass dahinter pädophilie steckt
und auch irgendwie so ein sex kult
steckt wo irgendwie frauen missbraucht
werden dann kann ich halt diese kunst
nicht mehr supporten und dann möchte ich
auch aktiv dafür eintreten dass dieser
mensch keine bühne bekommt einfach auch
aus solidarität mit menschen denen das
widerfahren ist und wo es keine
konsequenzen gab es aber der
vollständigkeit halber sollte ich
trotzdem noch mal die vorwürfe gegen
kelly sind höchstwahrscheinlich war es
wahnsinnig viele indizien wahnsinnig
viele zeuginnen videos aber zum
zeitpunkt der kampagne zumindest gab es
noch keine verurteilung der mann war
noch nicht im gefängnis das muss man es
gab die doku dazu es gab aber noch keine
verurteilung das muss man der
vollständigkeit halber vielleicht auch
noch mal sagen
interessant ist ja der punkt kontakt
schuld dass du eher weil du dich mit
jemandem abgegeben hass der mutmaßlich
straffällig geworden ist deswegen
gecancelt wurde ist und das ist ja also
das ist ja
nämlich anfangs du am problematischsten
für die selbst auch weil du hast ja
dadurch berufliche hindernisse gehabt
also nicht nur beruflich unbedingt würde
ich sagen ich glaube das schlimmste für
mich war also natürlich wir haben auch
zum beispiel finanzielle einbußen gehabt
dadurch also wir haben wir hatten
angebote mit leuten zusammen zu arbeiten
die dann erstmal sich zurückgezogen
haben weil es hieß ja geradezu
problematisch und das finde ich
natürlich bedenklich aber das finde ich
nicht so schlimm wie als personen die
selbst einer minderheit angehört den
rückhalt seiner eigenen community zu
verlieren das war für mich eigentlich so
die schlimmste erfahrungen im ganzen und
ich finde halt auch ich bin nicht ein
mensch der das nicht einsehen kann oder
so wenn er fehler macht und ich finde
man kann mit mir eigentlich ganz gut
reden und da fand ich auf jeden fall
sehr schade dass gerade die menschen so
wie ich zum beispiel die sich mühe geben
auch dinge anders zu machen auch dinge
besser zu machen dann mit denen
besonders hart ins gericht gegangen wird
und dann eben ja also ich fühle mich auf
jeden fall sehr so als wird kein
unterschied mehr machen eigentlich ob
ich was dazulernen und ob ich diesen
fehler sozusagen bereue und ob ich
irgendwie in zukunft anders handeln
würde oder nicht weil irgendwie ist man
so irreversibel raus bei ganz vielen
menschen ich würde gerne mal bei dem
punkt kontakt schuld bleiben weil das
ein spannendes ding ist das wenn man
selber also nachweislich unschuldig
agiert im öffentlichen raum und trotzdem
weil man sich mit den falschen personen
abgegeben hat vielleicht
repressalien befürchten muss wie geht's
dir gunnar ich meine du sitzt zum
beispiel mit zur person wir kennen jetzt
in den talkshows auf youtube canon epson
ist in der öffentlichen debatte gerade
eine persona non grata hat sich zu einer
solchen gemacht wirst du dafür
angefeindet oder oder gefeiert weder
noch weil ich eigentlich ja sozusagen
mit ihm debattieren und zu sagen also da
kann man jetzt so zu stehen wie man will
aber das gehe ich auch bewusst ein was
du hast jetzt gesagt zurecht erreichten
holocaust leugner ja was du sagst dass
er relativ schnell auf ihr hab ich bei
der meile der holocaust leugnung ist
auch nicht mehr innerhalb des hart aber
so kann man doch versuchen den zu
verstehen
man kann doch meine ja ja das ist eure
ansehen dialog war meine stimme sprechen
wenn ein mann in der wohnung muss ein
und nicht lasst das ist nicht die
diskussion sondern auch hier sogar man
muss ja erst mal mit jemandem sprechen
oder zumindest über diesen versprechen
ob es wirklich stimmt und dann muss man
ihn ja schon auch erst mal eine die wir
eben gesagt haben wenn wir jetzt einfach
nur sagen du bist ein holocaust leugner
du bist ein
dies und das jetzt irgendwas einfügen da
muss man sich ja auch er ich schätze er
sieht es selber nicht so und dann müsste
man ja auch sein bevor ich dann sage zu
recht völlig okay was die wie siehst du
das so und wenn er dann ja ja doch nicht
den holocaust dann ja aber ich sehe das
noch nicht dass dieses gespräch
vielleicht nehmen wir mal eben das
beispiel klarer zu machen ein end
weniger polarisierendes beispiel um das
ganz klar zu sagen hallo daraus leuten
da darf man ausgrenzen die sind nicht
grundgesetzkonform bitte weiter
ausgrenzen wenn es denn so ist
ich stelle meine fragen
florian schroeder kennen wir alle
kabarettist steht oft auch im fernsehen
ist in der links babbel wenn wir sie so
nennen wollen relativ oft relativ gut
gefeiert unter anderem auch weil jetzt
bei der querdenker demo in stuttgart
aufgetreten ist das fanden viele gut der
tritt aber auch zusammen mit dieter nuhr
und lisa eckardt zum beispiel im
fernsehen auf und dafür wurde er zum
beispiel auf twitter heftig angefeindet
zu recht also thema kontakt schuld als
künstler muss man darf nicht vergessen
es ist immer noch kunst gemacht und du
hast ja als künstler oder als
öffentliche präsidentensohn hast du ja
das ist ja deine entscheidungen
sich positioniert ist und wenn er das
für richtig hält mit diesen leuten
aufzutreten
da ist es dann ist es sein gutes recht
und dafür würde ich den kontakt schuld
oder so angreifen
auch weil ich dieter nuhr in dieser ecke
hat keine keine keine schuld an kreide
sondern ich bin für die ihre
positionierung fragwürdig aber ist es
nicht so dass ich sage hey das müssten
verschwinden so lange sich das in diesem
rahmen bewegt offensichtlich wenn es
eine nachfrage nach danach gibt leute
hört sich an
da gibt es halt auch eine gegenbewegung
die möglicherweise manchmal dann auch
gerne ich selber und dann trifft man
sich in der mitte aber das ist genau das
spannungsverhältnis das wir haben und
das dafür sorgt dass überhaupt kunst
entstehen kann und deshalb bin ich auch
nicht dafür dass man die rechte seite
einfach übels weg cancelled ja ich würde
auch da ansetzen und sagen das ding ist
halt und das hab ich ja zum beispiel
auch erlebt jetzt sind meine story so
dass gewalt in communitys oder auch
gewalt von männern gegen frauen
die wird sich ja nicht auflösen indem
man leute raus cancelled oder indem man
leuten einfach die plattform nimmt oder
dafür sorgt dass sie nie wieder arbeiten
können sage ich mal
das löst sich dadurch nicht und auch
scham kann nicht also jemanden
bloßzustellen jemanden öffentlich zu
schämen glaube ich ist nicht so effektiv
wie irgendwie zu schauen dass man diese
person versucht mit zu nehmen und
irgendwie ein bisschen also einfach
diskussionen sind der erste weg jedem
element hat sein umfeld und ich finde es
wichtig dass man im umfeld solche
auseinandersetzungen auch stattfinden
dass man nicht überall rausfliegt sage
ich mal
ich würde gerne in eine vierte runde
gehen es ist der versuch einer sommer
konsensrunde und vielleicht auch ja
vielleicht analysen und ich bin gespannt
ob ihr sie teilt oder nicht das ist ja
die frage ob wir hier zumindest auf
einer metaebene im konsens vielleicht in
teilen erreichen können also ein aspekt
der vielleicht gar nicht so sehr in
dieser dieser debatte vorkam ist ja
folgender manche player in öffentlichen
debatten
die haben gar kein interesse an konsens
sondern an diskurs hoheit na also den
geht es weniger um einsicht sondern um
überlegenheit hierzu
[Musik]
würdet ihr sagen ja weil das ist so ein
aspekt der in dieser diskussion die so
vorkam denn wir reden alle darüber wie
kann man besser miteinander reden und so
manche leute tun januar hat wollen sie
miteinander reden und eigentlich suchen
sie nur eine überlegenheit auf die
wahrscheinlich damit die nächste analyse
wahrscheinlich ist gar nicht so sehr
fehlende meinungsvielfalt das problem
sondern eine kaputte debattenkultur die
debattenkultur eigentlich nur richtig
gut funktioniert wenn sie in den
tageszeitungen aufgetragen worden ist
oder
also ich glaube wenn viele menschen
teilnehmen können und dass jeder kann
eine debatte teilnehmen immer sogar
manchmal zehn accounts gleichzeitig ich
glaube dann kann nichts gutes bei
rauskommen und ich glaube das ist auch
vielleicht ein zu großer standard der da
ins internet gesetzt wird
das internet ist ein toller haufen der
mir alles gut den letzten drei jahren
beschert hat aber es ist halt auch
einfach zu solchen ernsthafte debatten
nicht wirklich findet das auch in den
tag gut aber ich habe jetzt auch nicht
das internet gesagt eigentlich hätten
wir doch die beste debattenkultur aller
zeiten weil zum ersten mal alle wirklich
teilnehmen können es ist argument ist
dass die debattenkultur nicht kaputt ist
sondern sie ist nur so vielfältig wie
sie noch nie war
und gerade in einem land mit
meinungsfreiheit wie wir es gott sei
dank sind es ist doch super dass allein
diese debatten kultur teilnehmen
gut ein konzept konkretisiert noch ein
bisschen also wenn wir konstruktive
debatten führen wollen egal ob jetzt im
analogen oder digitalen leben müssen wir
uns auf mindestmaß an sachlichkeit
einigen ein mindestmaß an respekt und
anstand zumindest also der wunsch wäre
mal gucken ob er zustimmt alle menschen
müssen alles sagen dürfen ohne angst zu
haben dass sie digital gelöscht werden
oder analog genutzt werden noch
schlimmer
aber ich finde sie sollten alle
irgendwie das zutrauen haben das dann
noch mal wirklich geprüft wird ob in an
den vorwürfen dran ist
das finde ich sollten wir uns als
gesellschaft leistung ich hin muss schon
ein bisschen großen gerade auch
aushalten müssen es bringt ja auch
nichts dazu sagen ja das darf irgendwie
nicht sein oder man muss es sagen dürfen
ohne dass also an wen richtet sich diese
rede an wen richtet sich dieser aufruf
so seid bitte alle lieb nähe sind halt
nicht alles es gibt nun mal irgendwie
auch neid und hass und irgendwie einfach
zwischenmenschlich nicht so schöne
sachen und das wird es auch weiterhin
geben aber ich finde wir müssen halt
irgendwie formen dafür finden wie wir
das wieder zivile hinkriegen shitstorm
ist auch gut also shitstorm und streiten
ist ja ein neuer produkte war aber so
schön und canton eben nicht eine sache
muss ich noch sagen weil wir die auch
noch nicht angesprochen haben das
geschäftsmodell vieler digitale
plattform basiert darauf dass leute
emotionalisiert werden um möglichst viel
hass und plätze verteilen damit die
leute länger drauf bleiben denn dann
kann ich mehr werbung verkaufen
das ist ja wahr technisches problem
bitte beispiel na ja wenn ich wenn ich
möglichen hat formal nicht so naja
facebook um mutmaßlich lebt das
geschäftsmodell davon dass die leute
immer realisiert werden sollen und
negative emotionen halten einen länger
dabei ich fasse einmal ganz kurz
zusammen es gab ein ewiges hin und her
sodass so ihr habt euch zumindest in
teilen angenähert und ich habe auch
tatsächlich das gefühl das spielfeld
zeigt ungefähr den lauf der diskussion
ich hoffe ihr sieht es ähnlich
denn es gab dann doch viele
überschneidungen auch wenn ihr auf
verschiedenen seiten also vermeintlich
steht herzlichen dank dafür am ende sage
ich immer und das meine ich wirklich
vollkommen ernst wir müssen auch was
dieses thema cancelte anbelangt alles
erwarten auch dass gute vielen dank
danke
ich habe die diskussion als sehr
produktiv empfunden
wir sind uns nicht ganz einig geworden
aber ich glaube das liegt auch daran
dass das phänomen kämpfe karte einfach
so groß ist dass man es gar nicht so
schnell ab graphen kann wenn man sich
auf so einer abstrakten weise mit einem
thema auseinandersetzt vielleicht die
andere seite auf gar nicht sieht die
haben ja auch ein bedürfnis und ein
grund warum sie die dinge so sehen und
da etwas genauer einzutauchen und dazu
zu hören hat mich vielleicht ich weiß
nicht ein bisschen sensibler dafür
gemacht ich glaube grundsätzlich werden
wir cancel culture bewerten dann müssen
wir uns manchmal ein bisschen von
unserer eigenen perspektive distanzieren
und überlegen hey warum reagiert die
linke babel so warum reagiert die rechte
babbel so weil ich glaube um wirklich
einen blick auf kunst und satire und so
weiter
diese ganzen sachen die kanzel kalte
hervorrufen können objektiv bewerten zu
können draußen die eine gewisse distanz
ja also das hat mir eigentlich mein bild
auch bestätigt dass der dass die jungen
generation
tatsächlich werde ich die welt besser
machen will und dass die mieter zum
dialog so ein gerät oder aufruft das
verstehe ich auch und das gehe ich auch
in gewissem maße mit
aber nicht grenzenlos war für mich eben
vieles auch zeitgeist gestört ist ich
glaube was wir auf jeden fall zu lassen
sollten und was er einziehen ein ziel
sein sollte für den öffentlichen und
privaten des kurses ist dass wir es
zulassen sollten dass man sich
entschuldigt und fehler eingesteht und
vielleicht sich sogar verbessert ich
glaube davon profitieren wir alle
und niemand egal auf welcher seite der
diskussionsrunde er oder sie heute stand
ist perfekt oder ein ein bildnis
moralischen moralischer überlegenheit
ich finde das wichtig dass wir einander
kritisieren nicht um einander zu
zerstören da um uns über eine person zu
stellen sondern aus solidarität und
wohlwollend und auch mit dem gedanken im
hinterkopf dass diese person diese
kritik auch aufnehmen und reflektieren
und ihr verhalten verbessern kann was
mir heute besonders gut gefallen hat ist
dass das format zu herrlich aufgegangen
ist also jeder und jeder hatte seine
eigene feste position aber dann hat man
eben doch oft gesehen dass die eine oder
andere person so ein kleines schrittchen
brauchen großen schritt aber nur ein
ganz kleines schrittchen auf die andere
seite zugegangen ist und so sind halt
diskussionen gerade solche diskussionen
die sind nicht schwarz weiß sondern
wahnsinnig viele zwischenschritte und
das hat man heute glaube ich wunderbar
gesehen wenn euch dieses format so gut
gefällt wie mir dann könnt ihr hier
unseren kanal abonnieren da oben gibt es
ein weiteres video 13 fragen und hier
unten haben wir noch ein anderes video
zum thema in diesem sinne vielen dank